Hallo. Zum kurz möchte ich mich vorstellen.
Zeitstärke ist mein Name und ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Und ich werde zuerst einige allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Danach werde ich direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwörden übergehen.
Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Magda Schmidt.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname langsam buchstabieren?
Der Vorname ist M-A-G-D-A Magda.
Und der Familienname Schmidt, S-C-H-M-I-T.
Und wie alt sind Sie? Und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt. Bin geboren am 11.06.69.
60? Okay. Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Seite?
Ich bin 168 und ich wiege zur Zeit 79 kg.
79 kg?
79 kg, ne?
79 kg.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Seite?
Frau Schmidt, oder?
Ja.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Sie müssen sich mal meinen rechten Arm angucken.
Der ist so geschwollen und er tut mir auch so weh.
Der ist auch ganz heiß und rot.
Das hat vor ein paar Tagen angefangen,
dass der ein bisschen geschwollen war.
Ich versuche den zu bewegen.
Auch die Haut ist so richtig prall und glänzt.
Und das ist auch so ein bisschen gerötet. Sieht ganz komisch aus.
Seit ein paar Tagen haben Sie eine Schwellung am Beinen.
Und welche Seite ist betrunken?
Nicht am Bein, am Arm.
Arm, achso. Am rechten Arm.
Ja, und ich bin Rechtshänderin.
Das schränkt mich schon sehr ein, dass ich diesen Arm so schlecht bewegen kann.
Der ist ganz schwer.
Was haben Sie gesagt? Sind Sie Rechtshänderin?
Ich bin Rechtshänderin. Ich brauche meine rechte Hand eigentlich.
Achso. Sie benutzen immer rechte Hand.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und geschwollen? Und hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, einen Unfall hatte ich nicht. Nein.
Keinen.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden belöstlich aufgetreten?
Ja, also mit einem Alp fing das an.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht erklären.
Und wie groß sind die Schwellung?
Meinen Sie Ödem oder eine...
Ja, ja. Der Arm ist richtig viel dicker als der andere.
Und haben Sie einen Insektschicht bemerkt am betroffenen Bereich?
Ein Insektenstich.
Nein, ich kostet jetzt keine Insekten mehr.
Da ist auch nichts, was irgendwie juckt oder so.
Nee, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Und Sie haben auch Schmerzen und Strahlen, die Schmerzen,
Schmerzen irgendwo in Ihrem Körperteil aus?
Nein, die sind in dem Arm halt nicht.
Ich kann den Arm halt nicht gut bewegen.
Ja, gut damit ist natürlich auch die Hand irgendwie so ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Achso.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen im ganzen Arm?
Oder die Hand?
Der ist ja komplett geschwollen und fühlt sich also prall und schmerzhaft an.
Und wer haben Sie welche Bewegungen, Einschränkungen?
Ich meine, können Sie einfach den Arm nach oben herben oder zum Faust ballen?
Die Faust kann ich schon ballen, aber ich kann den zum Beispiel nicht gut abknicken im Ellenbogen.
Und der ist schwer, der Arm fühlt sich so schwer an.
Also haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, den Arm zu strecken?
Ja, ich halte immer so ein bisschen mit der anderen Hand so fest, aber es ist blöd.
Es ist auch blöd und gibt es am Betroffenen Bereich ein Wunde oder Hermatomabschiffungen?
Also ein Verletzter?
Ich habe mich zumindest nicht bemerkt und so einen blauen Fleck habe ich da nicht.
Hatten Sie schon einmal in der Vergangenheit gleiche Beschwerte?
Nein.
Oder zum ersten Mal haben Sie so gegessen?
Das ist zum ersten Mal so, ja.
Und was für eine Schmerzen haben Sie?
Können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Stechen, brennen, Schmerzen?
Stechen eigentlich nicht, vielleicht eher so drückend, drückend würde ich sagen, ja.
Und haben Sie ein Gefühl oder fühlen Sie sich am Betroffenen Bereich, am rechten Arm ein?
Kreppbeln, Taubheitsgefühl oder am Eisenaufen?
Nein, sowas habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ne, also Taub ist es nicht.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Oh, habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber, weiß ich, kann ich Ihnen wirklich nicht sagen, also, ja, vielleicht fühle ich mich ein bisschen weh, aber der Arm fühlt sich jedenfalls warm an, ja.
Aber ich selber, mein Kopf oder so würde ich sagen, ist nicht heiß.
Hab ich richtig beinstanden und am ganzen Arm gibt es Rötung und Schwellung und auch Überwärmung.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und am welchen Bereich sind die Beschwerden angefangen?
Also ich meine hier oben im oberen Armbereich, dass es da angefangen hat.
Und haben Sie auch Schwierigkeiten, den Kopf zum Drehen oder Neigen?
Mit dem Kopf habe ich nichts.
Hoffe ich doch mal, ja.
Okay.
Und vielleicht haben Sie bemerkt oder können Sie bitte mir sagen, dass die Hände ein bisschen blass aussieht?
Na, blass ist die Hand nicht nö.
Okay, kein Problem beim Durchbelutung, kein Problem beim Nervensystem.
Nur haben Sie Rötung und vielleicht das ist ein Infektion, ich bin noch nicht sicher.
Und ich möchte gerade auch über Ihre allgemeine Informationen sprechen.
Ich meine, hier hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der Rest der Zeit verändert.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen, aber eigentlich so.
Ja, so ein Kilo habe ich mal zugenommen, aber nicht viel.
Ja, wie viel Kilo und in welcher Zeitraumrahmen?
Also in den letzten 6-8 Wochen, ja, habe ich mal ein Kilo zugenommen.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie gesagt?
Ein Kilo.
Ein Kilo, das ist nicht so viel, aber...
Ne, eben, das schwankt ja immer mal ein bisschen.
Okay, und ist Ihnen Öbel oder haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Nein, nein, mein Arm tut mir nur weh, also sonst geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut,
aber der Arm halt, ne?
Ja, ja, und haben Sie noch andere aktuelle Beschwerden?
Ich sehe jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen dann auch sagen kann, die sonst.
Ich wäre eigentlich ganz zufrieden, ja.
Weil ich frage gerade die allgemeine Informationen über die allgemeine
Frequenzinformationen und haben Sie die Willigkeiten beim Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nee, nee, also zum Glück nicht.
Super, und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie die Willigkeiten, einen zu schlafen
und einen durch zu schlafen?
Also jetzt die letzte Tage habe ich tatsächlich nicht so gut geschlafen,
aber in aller Weise kann ich gut schlafen, ja.
Manchmal kann ich nicht so gut einschlafen, aber wenn ich dann erst mal schlafe,
dann ist es gut und jetzt aber die letzten Tage bin ich tatsächlich auch nachts mal wach geworden,
weil ich dann nicht wusste, wo ich mit dem Arm hin soll und das hat ein Weh getan, ja.
Okay, und frage jetzt den Sie gerade 56 Jahre hat, aber haben Sie schon Monatsbelüten?
Bekommen Sie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich bin schon in der Menopause.
Und jetzt möchte ich auch über Ihre Krankengüste sprechen
und gibt es bei Ihnen wichtige oder krönche Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, das, was so jeder hat, natürlich ein bisschen hoher Blutdruck und ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfeldwerte
und so, aber was wahrscheinlich auch wichtig ist, ich hatte, aber schon vor vielen Jahren,
schon 14 Jahre her, hatte ich auf der rechten Seite eine Brustoperation, weil ich ein Brustkrebs hatte.
Okay, eine rechten Brust wurde entfernt, habe ich richtig verstanden?
Die wurde nicht entfernt, nein, nein, das ist brusstehaltend operiert worden.
Ach so, okay. Sind Sie gerade gesund, oder?
Ja, ja.
Okay, und vor 14 Jahren haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, genau, ich bin da regelmäßig auch in Kontrolle eigentlich, ja.
Super, haben Sie gerade keine Beschwerden zu haben.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass auch Sie an Artilial-Lechipotenie oder Brutbruchdruck leiden
und was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Oh, wie heißt denn das? Ich nehme Konko 5 und Diovan 160.
100? Können Sie bitte die Dosin nochmal sein?
Diovan 160, da nehme ich eine morgens und Konko 5 auch eine morgens.
Okay, super. Und beide haben Sie beide Medikamente am Morgen?
Ja, genau.
Okay, und seit wann leiten Sie an Brutbruchdruck?
Das hat man so vor neun Jahren ungefähr festgestellt, Mann.
Und wegen Brutsfettwerte nehmen Sie auch Medikamente an?
Ich glaube nicht, nee. Also Sie waren auch jetzt nicht so furchtbar hoch.
Nicht so viel hoch.
Also ein bisschen erhöht halt, ne?
Und sind bei Ihnen noch andere Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, was natürlich noch wichtig ist, ich habe auf der rechten Seite vor einem Jahr
ein neues Hüftgelenk bekommen.
Rechte Hüfte, oder?
Wegen Abnutzung.
Ja, so ja, Atrose oder Abnutzung.
Ja, genau.
Wann wurden Sie genau operiert?
Ja, das ist ein gutes Jahr, ja.
Gutes Jahr, was meinen Sie?
Ja, etwas über ein Jahr, also das war in August vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr.
Und hat die Operation Komplikationslos verlaufen?
Komplikationslos verlaufen, ja, ja, da war, also das Gott hat alles gut gegangen.
Super.
Und ich möchte auch darüber eine Frage stellen.
Wann waren Sie in Lester seit Wegen Brustkrebs zum Ausgegangen?
Also ich bin vor drei Monaten zu der regelmäßigen Kontrolle bei Frauenarzt gewesen.
Aber die Brust hat ja nur so geguckt und so eine Ultraschalluntersuchung ist vielleicht so vom Jahr gelaufen.
Okay, und hatten Sie dagegen eine Chemotherapie oder Radiotherapie bekommen?
Ja, ich habe, es ist operiert worden, danach habe ich Strahlentherapien bekommen, kurzfristig, aber nur kurz.
Okay, und ich möchte auch fragen, haben Sie ein Nigelknochen oder ein Knoten am rechten Oberarm oder am Achsenhölle bemerkt?
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, ne?
Okay, dann ich möchte auch weiter machen.
Sind Sie auch etwas allergisch oder reagieren Sie auf etwas allergisch?
Ja, ich habe so ein Heuschnupfen so ein bisschen, das heißt, bestimmte Blütenpollen, da habe ich Probleme.
Okay, seit wann leiden Sie und nehmen Sie dagegen etwas?
Ja, ich nehme da so Medikament, das ist Zitirizin und das nehme ich aber natürlich nur, wenn ich Probleme habe.
Weil wer darf?
Ja, okay.
Und seit Kindheit leiden Sie daran, oder?
Ja, das ist immer schlimmer geworden eigentlich, ja, aber eher im Erwachsenenalter, also mit 25 oder so, dass es angefangen hat.
Okay, und sind bei Ihnen Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nahrungsmittel oder Arzneimittel?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, eigentlich bisher bin ich gut klargekommen.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Sie meinen jetzt gegen Covid?
Ja, alle empfüngen als Kindheit bisher.
Und Kindheit bin ich natürlich geimpft worden, dass man damals so alles gekriegt hat.
Und ja, was ich jetzt in letzter Zeit habe, habe ich nochmal die Grippeimpfung bekommen.
Und gegen Covid bin ich auch viermal geimpft.
Und reisen Sie oft oder waren Sie in Lester seit im Ausland?
Nein, also ja, wir waren im Urlaub mal, im Sommerurlaub waren wir in Dänemark, aber ja, das ist ja auch schon wieder lange her.
Super, okay.
Und rauchen Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Nee, geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Und konsumieren Sie Alkohol?
Regalmäßig oder gelegentlich?
Also Alkohol regelmäßig nun gar nicht, aber hin und wieder schon, ja.
Also wenn es noch etwas zu feiern gibt oder ja, wenn es ein besonders gutes Essen gibt oder ja, wenn man Besuch hat oder so, ja, dann trinke ich schon mal ein bisschen.
Und hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich nie Kontakt gehabt, nee.
Ja, ich muss auf jeden Fall fragen, machen Sie bitte, unternehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Und ich möchte auch gerade jetzt über Ihre Familien sprechen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie, in Ihren Nähen Familie, zum Beispiel Vater, Mutter oder Geschwester, wichtig oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Also eine Schwester hat genauso wie ich auch Großkrebs, das hat man vor einem Jahr festgestellt, die ist noch in der Behandlung, sind meine jüngere Schwestern, ne.
Und mein Bruder, der ist älter gewesen, der hatte tatsächlich ein Herzinfarkt und der ist verstorben, der ist gar nicht alt geworden, ja.
Und mein Vater hatte auch ein Herzinfarkt, ja.
Er hat ihre Eltern gerade?
Mein Vater lebt nicht mehr, nee, der ist verstorben.
Ja, da bin ich Ihre Bruder.
Und ja, bei meiner Mutter, die hat genau das gleiche, ich habe überall, habe ich das richtige mitgekriegt, meine Mutter hat auch ein künstliches Hüftgelenk, ja.
Was, meine Sie, ein künstliches Hüftgelenk?
Ein künstliches Hüftgelenk, genau wie ich auch.
Ach so, ja.
Super.
Und ich habe leider vergessen, diese Frage zu stellen, sind Sie schon in die Rente gegangen oder arbeiten Sie?
Ich arbeite eigentlich noch, ja, ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraum.
Freisicher.
Arbeiter also im Reisebüro, ne.
Ach so, Sie arbeitet in Reisebüro, sind Sie selbstständig?
Nein, nein, ich bin da angestellt.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, die sind aber natürlich schon groß, ne.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Super, so sagen Sie, danke.
Und leben Sie zusammen mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, die Kinder sind aus dem Haus, aber mit meinem Mann lebe ich zusammen, ja.
Okay, super.
Ich habe dir alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe nicht so viel erzählt, also ja, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch als Information geben könnte, ja.
Und ja, jetzt möchte ich natürlich wissen, woher das kommen kann und, ach ja, was man natürlich dagegen tun kann.
Ich will ja wieder arbeiten, ne.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Leider kann ich direkt sagen, was Sie darunter leiden.
Worunter Sie leiden?
Worunter Sie leiden.
Zuerst muss ich Ihnen, muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und einige Laborwerte kontrollieren.
Gegebenenfalls oder eventuell brauchen wir auch einige operative Maßnahmen, die Detaniertes und Verzweifelungen.
Operative?
Operative.
Operative, okay.
Ja, ich klingt schon besser, ja.
Dann können wir die Entscheidung treffen.
Wie es weitergeht.
Ja, nach der Ergebnisse der Tester und der Besuchenden können wir, sollen wir widersprechen.
Ja, das klingt gut, ja, okay, gut.
Ja, dann warten Sie bitte ein bisschen.
Ja, ich gehe da nie ins Wartete, ne?
Ja, dann ich werde Ihnen bei Schalke zeigen.
Mhm.
Okay.
Aber sehr schön, würde ich sagen, ja.
Hat noch jemand, der sich sagt?
Ja, darf ich fragen?
Ja, immer.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 leichte, 10 sehr stark ist Schmerzen, bedeutet.
Ja, je nachdem, was ich mit dem Arm mache, also ich würde sagen so zwischen 5 und 6,
so ein bisschen über der Hälfte.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas angenommen?
Nee, was ich versucht habe, so ein bisschen zu kühlen, aber das war mir jetzt so ungemütlich
bei dem kalten Wetter.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Immer.
Tritt die Schmerzen plötzlich oder eher langsam auf?
Es hat plötzlich angefangen, ist aber stärker geworden, die Beschwerden, ne?
Mhm.
Ich habe es stärker geworden.
Okay, danke schön.
Und wann waren Ihre letzte onkologische Untersuchungen kontrolliert?
Das ist fast ein Ja, ja.
Hatte aber auch gefragt, ne?
Aha, okay.
Und wann haben Sie Ihre Blutdruck gemessen?
Blutdruck?
Dann habe ich gar nicht gemessen, also jetzt die Tage.
Weil ich, also ich mache das nicht regelmäßig.
Da ist ja...
Ja, jetzt kommt noch eine Frage.
Hatten Sie schon diese Schmerzen gehabt oder das ist erst das Mal?
Das ist zum ersten Mal, hat der Kollege aber auch schon gefragt, ja?
Ja, ich gelb.
War es gut?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Fahrveränderungen insbesondere Eiterbildung im Arm bemerkt?
Eine Eiterbildung?
Eiterbildung.
Eiteransammlung.
Nein, nein.
Da ist also nichts, irgendwie so eine Stelle, die eklig aussieht.
Nein, nein, da ist nix.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Tuchta?
Ich habe zwei Tüchter, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Oh, jetzt muss ich eben mal rechnen, wie alt Sie sind.
Ähm, die sind 22 und 24.
Okay, danke schön.
Sie haben diese Wichtferste seit einigen Tagen.
Seit wenigen Tagen, ja, also zwei, drei Tage, ja.
Wo genau, oder wie genau diese Wichtferste haben?
Eintagen oder zwei Tage, drei Tage?
Also ich habe das gemerkt, dass der Arm irgendwie anders war vor drei Tagen,
das erste Mal und dann vor zwei Tagen habe ich gedacht,
hm, der wird ja immer dicker und jetzt wurde das immer schlechter.
Und dann bin ich halt gekommen.
Also vor zwei Tagen kann man eigentlich sagen, ging es los, ja.
Gibt es etwas, das dich schmecken oder beschwerden,
lehnt das oder fest, haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, Bewegung hat natürlich verschlechtert, ne,
dass klar, deswegen habe ich den Arm immer so ein bisschen festgehalten.
Und wenn ich den schön ruhig gehalten habe,
dann war es ein bisschen besser, ja.
Also auch zum Beispiel, wenn ich im Bett gelegen habe
und den irgendwie so gut gelagert habe, dann war es okay, ja.
Gibt es etwas, was diese Beschwerden auslösen?
Wie zum Beispiel im Krankenhaus, IFA,
irgendwelche Medikamente, haben Sie eingenommen?
Nein, ich war nicht im Krankenhaus in letzter Zeit.
Es gibt eigentlich, also für mich kann ich nicht erklären,
warum das mit einmal losgegangen ist.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Herzprobleme?
Herzstraßen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Atemnot?
Nein, auch nicht.
Herzknopfen?
Ja, mein Herzknopfen natürlich, aber nicht mehr als sonst, ja.
Wir können?
Ja, ich kann anfangen, die Patienten vorzustellen,
aber ich habe gerade keine aktuelle Diagnose.
Nicht?
Vielleicht arbeiten wir uns da ja so ein bisschen drauf hin, ja.
Okay, dann darf ich anfangen?
Ja, natürlich.
Und Frau Magda Schmitz, 56-jährige Patientin,
stellte sich heute bei uns wegen vor vier Tagen plötzlich aufgetretener
und Ödem, Rötung und Überwärmung am ganzen Rechten an vor
und begleitet von Spannern der Schmerzen am Betroffenenbereich.
Und die Patienten erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen mit der Seite
schlimmer geworden sind und es gibt auch Bewegungseinschränkungen
und Bewegungseinschränkungen am Betroffenenbereich.
Und die Patientin fühlt sich fieberig, aber trotzdem hat sie die Fieber nicht gemessen.
Das Fieber, hm?
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf eine Gewicht zunehmend von einem Kilogramm
innerhalb sechs Wochen und in so einem Nied wegen aktueller Beschwerden
unauffällig und die Patientin leidet an arteriale Hypotonie
seit 15 Jahren, dagegen nimmt sie Konko 5 Milligramm und Tiawon 106 Milligramm
morgens einmal vor, einmal ein.
Und die Patientin leidet auch und ja Blut hochwert, Blutfett,
oder erhöchste Blutfette, und dagegen nimmt sie
ich habe leider nicht geschrieben, aber sie im Prastatin, nichts.
Nein, sie nimmt nichts.
Vielleicht habe ich falsch erinnert.
Und die Patient hat sich vor 40 Jahren eine Brustoperation unterzogen.
Damals wurde den Brust nicht entfernt.
Die Brust, hm?
Die Brust nicht entfernt.
Und der Patient wurde vor einem Jahr, oder bei der Patientin,
wurde eine Totalendeprothese recht,
oder Totalendeprothese höft, recht angelegt.
Und die Patientin reagiert allergisch.
Nein, die Patientin leidet allergische Renitis,
dagegen nimmt sie bei Bedarf Citrizintablette.
Und sie ist nicht raucherin und trinkt gelegenlich Alkohol
und die Traugen, die Kontakt mit Traugen wurden verneint,
und in der Familienanamnese finden sich bei der Vater,
bei dem Vater Corona-Herz-Krankheit,
dagegen ist der Vater gestorben.
Daran ist der Vater gestorben,
und bei der Mutter leidet,
und die Schwester der Patientin leidet an Mama Karzinum.
Und der Bruder der Patientin ist wegen,
wegen nach einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Ja, die alle wichtigen Informationen sind dabei.
Und möchten Sie einige Frage stellen?
Ja, also wie ist die Frau sozial aufgestellt?
Ach so, sie ist Reiseverkauferin.
Reiseverkehrskaufraum, schwieriges Wort.
Ja, also sie arbeitet in einem Reisebüro, ne?
Sie arbeitet in einem Reizenbüro
und sie ist verheiratet, hat drei gesunde Kinder
und sie lebt mit ihrer Familie.
Ja, was vermuten Sie denn jetzt,
was fehlt der Patientin?
Ja, zuerst habe ich gedacht,
dass es nur eine Lymphöder ist.
Aber sie haben auch gesagt,
dass es sich eine Rötung und Überwärmung befindet.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht,
dass es eine Inflammation sein soll.
Deswegen, ich habe gerade keine Diagnose,
ich bin nicht sicher.
Aber ja, so haben wir ja schon mal zwei verschiedene,
was könnte das Differenzialdiagnose denn noch sein?
Die kam ja gerade zwei Sachen noch.
Ach so, das ist der erste Differenzialdiagnose,
würde ich eine Erezipell sagen.
Ein Dermatitis oder eine Erezipellhaut,
eine Entfernt-Haut-Infektion.
Gut, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ich würde zuerst die Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich die Stadion der Schwellung kontrollieren.
Ja, wie machen Sie das?
Einfach drücken auf der Haut.
Und wie noch?
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin nicht sicher.
Ach so, ich erfordere es.
Ich erfordere, dass die Patienten die Hände aufheben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe nur beide Hände gezeigt, beide Arme.
Ach so, vergleichen.
Ja, vergleichen.
Ja, ich muss zu anderen Armen vergleichen.
Mit dem anderen Arm vergleichen, ja.
Also mit dem anderen Arm vergleichen.
Ja, das ist das, dass man guckt, ist der Arm wirklich?
Ja, Sie haben nichts.
Und ich würde auch die Bewegungseinschränkungen messen oder kontrollieren,
die Artritis oder die andere Situationen auszuschließen.
Und danach würde ich...
Was machen Sie noch?
Es kam noch ein paar Hinweise hier.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Also den Puls würde ich kontrollieren abtasten und die Durchblutung würde ich kontrollieren.
Deswegen habe ich diese Frage gestellt,
haben Sie ein Blasehaus, die auf der Hände hauthaben.
Würde ich die Motorik, Durchblutung und Sensibilitation kontrollieren?
Ja, neurologisch.
Ja, und wo nach gucken Sie noch?
Bei der Inspektion.
Gucken Sie bei der Inspektion.
Denken Sie mal an Ihre Differenzialdiagnose, Ihre SIPEL.
Was würden Sie da suchen?
Bei der R-Zipel erwarte ich tatsächlich eine begrenzte Rötung.
Da kam gerade der Hinweis von Dr. Pruppel.
Sie haben nach Insektenstil und nach Abschürfung gefragt.
Ja, bei der Anamnese gab es keine Hinweise auf die Ritzpel.
Sie haben recht, die Stichstelle würde ich kontrollieren.
Ob es eine Wunde gibt, eine offene Wunde an dem Arm, die die Patientin vielleicht gar nicht wahrgenommen hat.
Und die Knoten würde ich kontrollieren.
Die Lymphknoten kontrollieren, sehr gut.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie noch mit der Patientin?
Nach einer detaillierten körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich die Laborwerte kontrollieren.
An welchem Arm nehmen Sie Blut ab?
Ach so, am gesunden Arm.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und welche Laborwerte lassen Sie bestimmen?
Ich würde eine große Blutbild und CHP und BCG, wie die Entzündungsparameter kontrollieren.
Was noch wichtig?
Was ist noch wichtig im Labor?
Krebs oder Tumormarken.
Die meine ich jetzt nicht, die könnte man vielleicht auch mitchecken.
Die, die mehr um Trombose auszuschließen oder eben Hinweis auf eine Trombose zu haben.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und was machen Sie dann noch für eine Untersuchung?
Dann würde ich Ultrasonografie oder Dopplersonografie eröffnungen oder selbst machen.
Was können Sie da unter Umständen sehen?
Meinen Sie, was kann ich herausfinden?
Ja.
Bei der Doppler-Untilung würde ich die Flüssgeschwindigkeit machen.
Ja, ich meine das. Die Blutfluss und die Geschwindigkeit der Blut, oder des Blutes, das würde ich kontrollieren und messen.
Und was könnten Sie unter Umständen noch erkennen?
Lernst-Nufknoten.
Möglicherweise, ja, die kann man glaube ich auch sehen im Ultraschall, genau.
Bei der Doppler-Untilung kann man die Verschlüsse oder Verengungen feststellen.
Ja, genau, dass es eine Protokollung gibt.
Ach so.
Gut.
Okay, ja, dann gucken Sie mal, was mit der Patientin ist.
Wie wäre denn die Therapie, wenn die Patientin tatsächlich eine Venenentzündung hat oder eine Thrombose?
So als würde ich die Schmerzen lindern.
Schmerzenteil, danach Anticoagulationstherapie würde ich bestimmen.
Sehr gut, ja.
Und, was noch?
Und, ein Standeinlage oder Ballon dilatation wie, also wie heißt das diese?
Das wäre hier nur beim Verschluss, ne?
Ja, aber was gibt es noch außer Anticoagulation, was gibt es noch für ein konservatives Verfahren?
Wenn es ein Thrombosik.
Denken Sie mal, analog zum Bein.
Was machen Sie, wenn jemand eine Thrombose im Bein hat?
Was kriegt er dann?
Wer kriegt der Anticoagulation und was noch?
Die, meine Sie, die allgemeine Massnahme, zum Beispiel nach der Anticoagulationstherapie, würde ich eine Strufe oder Kompressionsstrufe...
Ja, die braucht sie jetzt schon.
Ach so.
Die braucht sie jetzt schon. Die braucht jetzt einen Armstrumpf, ja?
Eine Passagierung.
Ich habe leider nicht die Nukle erfahrt.
Die können Armst.
Ja, genau.
Gut, ja, dann schauen Sie mal, was bei der Patientin tatsächlich dahinter steckt, ob sie ein Erisipelat.
Wenn sie ein Erisipelat braucht sie natürlich Hochdose oder Diplose.
Dann solltet ihr sie auch stationär aufnehmen.
Und da vielleicht ist es ja tatsächlich nur eine kleine Venenentzündung, dann würden wir sie vielleicht ja auch bandagieren und hiperinisieren und dann könnte sie nach Hause gehen.
Alles klar.
Gut, ja, ich muss jetzt dazusagen.
Ich fand ja schon mal toll, dass sie überhaupt aufs Lymphedemien gekommen sind.
Ich habe fast zehn Jahre lang in einer lymphologischen Ambulanz gearbeitet als Sekretärin.
Und deswegen ist das ein bisschen mein Leib- und Magenthema.
Und ja, die große Baustelle sind tatsächlich die Erisipäne nach Mamakazinum oder auch die aufflackernen Lymphedemen nach, auch lange Zeit nach einer Mamakazinum-Operation.
Das ist so krass, die Leute rechnen da gar nicht mehr damit, weil es ist schon so lange zurückliegt.
Die haben praktisch die Krankheit schon abgehakt und mit einem Mal kommt da noch wieder irgendwas.
Und deswegen ist das also eine wichtige Information.
Insofern, das ist eigentlich mein einziger Kritikpunkt.
Die Info, dass die Patientin zustand nach Mamakazinum hat, die hätte ich dem Oberarzt früher gegeben.
Also schon zu einer etwas früheren Phase.
Das ist ja wichtiger als zum Beispiel der Blutschrochdruck und die Blutfettwerte.
Das hat ja wirklich Relevanz für die potentielle Diagnose.
Ansonsten fand ich, dass sie spraflig eine ausgezeichnete Anamnese gemacht haben.
Es war nicht ganz so brillant in der Berichterstattung.
Da haben sie sich manchmal mit den Formulierungen klein wenig schwerer betan.
Aber ihr Deutsch ist wirklich ausgezeichnet.
Sie sprechen sehr, sehr gut.
Manchmal werden vielleicht die Fachbegriffe noch ganz gut,
dass sie eben auch sagen, sie hat eine Brust-Operation, sie hat eine Zustand am Amakazinum.
Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so realistisch in diesem speziellen Fall,
dass die Patientin so wenig über ihre Brustkrebserkrankung weiß.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch nicht viele Informationen über diese jeweiligen Fälle.
Das ist übrigens für Interessenten ein Mainzerfall.
Der ist in Mainz gelaufen.
Ich mache den nicht so oft, weil das so mein Hobby ist, da will ich nicht nerven.
Aber ich finde, sie haben sich wirklich sehr, sehr gut geschlagen.
Und sie haben tatsächlich auch gleich in die richtige Richtung weitergefragt.
Dass sie gefragt haben, Taubheitsgefühl, Kribbeln, Ameisen laufen, neurologische Störungen,
ganz klar und Blässe der Hand, ob dann ein Verschluss ist.
Also wirklich, das haben sie richtig, richtig gut gemacht.
Auch die Formulierung fand ich schön, haben sie bemerkt, nicht nur immer haben sie, haben sie.
Ja, wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Ich habe gerade keinen Termin, ich warte.
Sie sollten ganz schnell einen machen, ja?
Ja.
Gut, in zwei, drei Formulierungen habe ich direkt korrigiert, haben sie gemerkt.
Ja, und bei der speziellen Behandlung dann jetzt, na gut, wie gesagt,
das ist so ein bisschen mein Schwerpunkt gewesen, deswegen habe ich das so gerne gemacht.
Danke schön.
Und habe sie ein bisschen speziell gefragt und hoffentlich nicht so sehr geärgert.
Nein, aber sie haben das wirklich schön gemacht.
Und, ähm, irgendwas war noch bei der, bei der Familie in Anamnese, wie war das?
Ja, da habe ich glaube ich auch mal reinkorrigiert, dass ich gesagt habe,
man muss es anders formulieren.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ganz, ganz hohes Niveau, wo ich da jetzt rumgeklötert habe.
Ja, also, ne, war eine Top Anamnese, würde ich sagen, und eine sehr gute Berichterstattung auch an den Oberarmen.
Danke schön.
Ja.
Ich habe zum ersten Mal solche Fallen getroffen, deswegen vielleicht habe ich...
Aber war nicht die erste Anamnese?
Das ist nicht erste Anamnese, ich habe mehrmals mit meinen Freunden gemacht.
Ja, das ist natürlich so, aber, ähm, ja, so eine Ambientrombose ist ja nicht aus der Welt, ne, kann ja schon mal passieren.
Und eine Lymphideenamamakazinomen kann auch passieren und da kann auch speziell ein Irresipel kommen.
Und das ist übrigens wirklich so eine Sache.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Gynäkologen oft nicht aufklären über diese Option, dass da eine Lymphideen kommen könnte.
Ja, das ist den Leuten oft nicht klar, die sagen dann hinterher, hiermit, einmal wird mein Arm so dick und dann kommen sie an und verstehen das gar nicht.
Und ja, logisch klar, Lymphknoten weg oder was auch immer, ja.
Oder, potentiell natürlich auch Rezidiv, ganz großes Kino dann, ja.
Dann muss man natürlich auch gucken, ist da wieder was, ja, in zweifel Fall, wenn die anderen Sachen ausgeschlossen sind.
Ja, das ist schon, das ist schon also eine wichtige Geschichte.
Und ja, ich glaube, man sagt das schon auch den Patientinnen, dass sie auf der betroffenen Seite keine Blutnahme machen lassen sollen,
dass sie da nicht Blutdruck messen sollen.
Aber ob die das noch 15 Jahre tatsächlich noch so beherzigen, das weiß ich immer nicht.
Und ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob man das dann nicht doch irgendwann auch einfach nicht mehr so wichtig nimmt, weil das ist alles so lange her.
Ja.
Und es kann aber dann wirklich hart auf einen zurückfallen.
Und insofern, ja, haben wir mal einen schönen Lymphideen für die Bietes, was auch immer Fall gehabt.
Darf ich fragen?
Gerne.
Was ist dieser Fall, richtige Diagnose? Ist das Lymphadenitis?
Nein, es steht mit Bindestrick, Phebitis oder Lymphideen.
Kommt auf die Diagnose an. Also muss man genauer gucken, kann beides sein.
Trombo, Phebitis und Lymphadenitis.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, gerne.
Gut. Ja, so viel für heute Abend. Dr. Bubel sehen wir uns am Donnerstag.